foreign
[Music]
cast number 23 brought to you courtesy
of Jocko willing Productions we thank
Jocko and today uh we've taken our
studio uh to
um
Utah we're in Utah the Hebrew that's
right Heber City Utah to the
headquarters of of um
Mike Glover and we thank Mike for
letting us use his studio today for what
I feel is a one of our major sawcasts
and I wanted to start with a little uh
section from on the ground
in this case was it was June 1968 a
Recon team had been inserted into Oscar
8 our most notorious deadly of Targets
in i-cor for SOG at that time
in Watkins utter amazement the next
vehicle was a massive bulldozer it's
blade up in the air
an NBA Soldier signaling directions with
a flashlight
Watkins was barely over the bulldozer
when Along Came two Russian t-38 tanks
they're gun barrels facing aft their
external fuel tanks mounted just as the
manual said
it took more than three hours for the
NVA parade to pass and this is at night
as The Last of Us Rumblings grew faint
Watkins came out of his days and looked
around
he immediately saw rung who was one of
his indigenous team members crawling
towards him with a panicked look on his
face
Walkers had been so mesmerized by all
the traffic
he had forgotten about the young Brew
team members ER and rung they were with
him on the trail watch
when wrong reached him he could barely
talk
not proficient in English under the very
best of circumstances what he was now
attempting to tell Watkins bordered on
the incoherent
Watkins calmed him down as best as he
could
and made him start over
rung said he'd been watching the road
traffic just like Watkins and had been
as taken with it as he was
while he was staring at all the vehicles
passing by a hand had reached out from
the darkness and given his arm a shake
a mounting yard Soldier one of the NBA
from the North Vietnamese Army the enemy
had pressed into unwilling service said
it's your time for guard Duty
fortunately rung was too stunned to do
anything but not his head and grunt a
kind of acknowledgment
it was enough however and the NBA Monte
yard moved off into the brush
wrong was badly rattled and the definite
opinion that the three of them ought to
abandoned highway 92 which they had been
observing for the last three hours and
to the rest of the team as fast as
possible Watkins agreed he returned to
his team
so today it is my pleasure to introduce
Pat Watkins the man who was there one of
our historic SOG moments in time pat
welcome to the show more things still
glad to see you sober and deal with it's
earlier we did this early in the morning
for a change indeed I didn't know that
was it opportunity for you all right
well welcome and um that on that day
that mission that's indeed of all the
stories that we've written about heard
about facade over the years that's got
to be up there near the top five you're
on the watch and um
the NVA touches your teammate you're so
close to the enemy in that major Target
in a trail watch after watching three
hours of troops come by
and it's like your turn for guard Duty
uh so first just let us have a little
reaction as the team leader on RT at
that time St lion correct RT lion RT
lion it was you Pat why
um you're Pat we had little Lou to set
up and the third member was George
Godwin George thank you and you had
about three in ditch or five no I had
seven seven okay so your reaction I'm
sure that day and that night remains
Vivid in your memories I was just
thankful you didn't shoot him that would
have been the end of it all oh yeah
compromise this yeah
yeah it's one of those uh
people want me to take the lie detector
test and it's really really really true
but
it was it was really true and it uh
it was not only was it an eye-opener uh
the whole mission itself
as as you know Oscar 8 was a notorious
Target
uh Billy walls flying Covey one time
when three helicopters were shot down in
that that was 1967. in 1967. and I think
I was the first team to go back since
then it was right on the road system
and
I kept telling uh I went out on a VR in
a one of those u-10s that you know
Chinese flew for us on a VR and I made
halfway out there we started taking 37
Mike Mike this is 68. 68. yeah sure you
ain't nowhere Under Siege a case on yes
and of course we're
we're getting on h-34s and going into
layoffs the Marines are all looking at
us like are they going on r r where
these guys going yeah well that we
should do a little background on that
because at the time in June of 1968
there were six fobs that were related to
SOG during the secret war and caisson
fob 3 was opening for business and and
we're not me but you and other guys like
to troll uh were running missions out of
there and at the time the national
headlines were the NVA Siege went on for
77 days at caisson and the little told
story was uh fob3 Special Forces there
and we'll follow up with one of my
favorite sidebars stories that you had
while you're there but I just want to
set the stage yeah
the hand grenade and the Ambush that you
walked through but they didn't trigger
it but we'll come back to that because
first we got to deal with this story and
um so
the trail was 92 and was it one or two
other trails that was near that
intersection and the reason why first
we're in i-core near the DMZ and near to
Laos right and that's a major Junction
for NVA traffic heading south as you
witnessed firsthand right that's where
they broke off to go into the ass show
right and uh yeah one of those it was a
you know we always get these Highway
names to these dirt trails that you know
as you know that ran through Laos in
North Vietnam but it was a it was like a
junction there was 922 there and Trump
Park uh the city that was right on which
was a lay Ocean City was right on it was
it was kind of funny it was not a you
couldn't they couldn't bomb that City
because there was lay oceans in there
really yeah and it's when then you know
in 72 when I was over here again on your
third tour Duty yeah well I had you know
jury duty someone was interrupted by
other crap I had 27 months and total
total well and
you know these guys today held Asians
they do more than that on her birthday
oh I noticed multiple times yeah these
guys are unbelievable but anyhow to make
a long story short that uh this whole
operation when I went out there on the
BR and came back of course I didn't get
to pick an LZ but we've all ran through
that right that we're at the mercy of
the coverage to put us in or just the
helicopters getting shot at and said I'm
going to get these guys off this damn
bird before I don't get shot at anymore
so anyhow I came back and I I told Lou
in Georgia you know of course they were
concerned about the target we were
running and I said don't worry about it
I says my God I got shot out of ten
thousand feet we'll never get on the
ground so don't worry about it
and I don't know did you realize yeah
when I got on the ground the first thing
Lou did was grabbing me and said you
said we weren't going to come here
well and then getting back to the
serious side of that mission right after
you're inserted what happened to the
Slick that inserted you all you got shot
down yeah welcome to the secret world
and then they said
stay where you're at we're going to come
and pick you up you've got to go in and
get the crew out that they look out
they're going to shut down and I kept
saying well isn't that a danger zone
there
but when we were coming into the you
know typical you know I'm standing out
on the Slick right now getting ready and
Lou's got a hold of my lb for I don't
fall out become free fall qualified and
and I looked up and there's green
tracers coming at us and all aside and I
says ain't gonna abort this thing
what the hell is going on yeah and then
they let us off in a bomb craters
wow and you know and it had all that
water in the bottom you know sure
and one of my yards downers it's already
was on the Olympic swimming team trying
to get out of the water
because it was muddy he sliding into the
water oh no I I think they actually well
of course they didn't know we got in
right or they did they'd come and killed
us you know I mean what am I going
to hell I didn't know if my yards were
gonna you know take all their and
blend into hunter gatherers again you
know yeah because how long had you been
on RT line at that point I've been there
uh me and Shoff and Darren got there in
first of April and
you know as I told you before you know
we're still you know we're still taking
artillery and stuff all day and the
Marines are just yeah yeah every time of
the game resupply team came in Everybody
Run for the bunkers and stuff because
they'd opened up from coal rock across
the border shooting one right one five
twos at us and so just for the record uh
you also came in country November of 67
or December 16th I came in November
November and then your your first Duty
station with SOG was at Danang F will be
yeah we were the original one zeros we
opened up that camp was that right yeah
yeah build a road sure ran the first
mission when you're comma guys that
taught you when you went through and the
whole team got wiped out that was good
for our morale the first mission run out
of there and we were a cartoon well
again for the record they were talking
about Sergeant First Class of uh Paul
villarosa and we what you're referring
to is when doing 1967 myself Johnny
McIntyre Tony Harrell Rick gastisner
guys we had gone through commentary and
got recycled
and Paul worked with us at night and we
just came in and he had three previous
tours of Duty with special forces in
Vietnam he also had a tattoo across his
neck I said cut here yeah cut along the
line yes then he had two blue birds and
that was the day before we didn't have
no it wasn't like today everybody's got
you know right
no you were told we couldn't have
tattoos in the Marine Corps when I was
in the Marine Corps uh you know an
officer couldn't have a tattoo uh below
the elbow because it would show up in
these tws
and the Marines you know it had the
devil dog deal but just to give our our
viewers a sense of what the enemy was
Communist
the North Vietnamese Army uh you opened
up the camp in December the first
mission now is like just January 1st or
2nd of 1968 Paul Villa roses the 1-0 the
team they go in they get make a heavy
enemy contact
yeah they were they were cact that's
when we had these cack pads
you know in other words they had Surfer
code code names right and you like anime
inside would be orange one or something
like that and they they told us we had
to CAC message well that's that question
on Fox Mike yeah Fox Mike on FM radio
yeah that was ropc 25s yes or linusite
radios that once everybody left there
was nobody to talk to and sometimes they
worked sometimes if the battery went and
run out and here too I just that moment
in time before we get back to Oscar 8
was they almost everybody in the team
was killed except for one American yeah
who was left alive and then they came
back with a flamethrower and Lily
torched Villa Rose's body yeah they and
that was psychological warfare so the
one remaining Soldier would get
distracted come back and then tell what
happened but they didn't let him come
back yeah they took him right to Saigon
right never we never saw him again yeah
welcome to this dirty side of the secret
war in 1968. yeah it was it was crazy
too because uh
we are training they sent us to cam
doctor they called it one zero school
again that was the initial training for
facade then yeah dick Metals was running
it up there and uh I don't know if you
know Larry Mayne has Captain Manus I've
only known of Larry he was he's preceded
by his notoriety yeah and Larry was one
of the guys and we're out there doing
you know
drills on the airstrip because he
couldn't get off out because you know
when the camp got overrun in in May you
know yeah kid shot down all the planes
and killed a bunch this is again cam
duck cam duck and there's an excellent
book out on that Siege which is called
bait yeah you know I tell you they
called me up and wanted to know I said
no I was the case I wanted this thing
where I received
wow
yeah no kidding so let's get back to
Oscar 8. yeah so um after wrong alerts
you you return to the team the team gets
together and you moved on yeah I had to
take the point because nobody would move
oh is that right yeah I forgot that yeah
well you know these yards were so just
for the wrecking pad I never ran point
because my little people were better
than I was well yeah and for you to run
point but
you ran on a team that had been trained
these guys were you know were out of
breach cloths and crossbows when I got
there I tell you no the hand grenades
sure and how we're out there under siege
and Marines are getting killed all
around us and we're trying to do
immediate action drills in the country
and train so here you want to tell us
about the hand grenade story because one
more little song before we get back to
Oscar 8 because we got it covered up we
got a couple days we do we've got time
time's on our side brother yeah I got I
got in here I came from info before and
I was at one zero of St
moccasin and and I'd had nine missions
under my belt across the fence already
wow and so anyhow and I
[Music]
and we'll come back to hotel nine later
yeah for sure we got to talk about that
but anyhow we we got up there and it and
you know you hear these stories about
Cason what's going on there and
everything it's like
uh I had friends up there
that uh you know they disappeared too
just like everything I was shot to
helicopters and all this crap going on
then the Long Bay deal right where
George
George took uh you know uh quavo took
yeah went in and saved those guys that
they're yeah they had a relief force
that went in to Lang they after they've
been under Seas all night and uh at the
time Lieutenant Paul longgreer was there
and he was one of the survivors for the
night and he lost several of our good
men there yeah one of my best friends is
they never recovered his body though
right years later he was on an outpost
they had a mic they had their
the C1
Mike force was in there they came in to
reinforce the case right of course they
were in the same situation we were at
fob4 they had no wire
you know the CBS that come in and built
that bunker form they built the bunker a
case on for us too yeah and uh of course
I never went in that bunker that was
officer's country so
I didn't want us animals so there you
are with the hand grenade training yeah
the first thing I did I come in here
Mike Bingle was the one one he had taken
over the team and Mike had a tour and an
a team before he was on his second tour
and I knew Mike sure he was a little
walk from New York yeah and he could do
it was a mountain climber he'd sit there
and do pull-ups all day you know I said
ain't you gotten anything better to do
so anyway I I says we got us gotta see
what the ranger training these guys have
been through because we're ASAP we don't
know we're advisors we're here to uh to
get you guys ready for a combat
so I I had said well let's let's get to
the two things first is your rifles you
know has been cited and I give up on
that just late you know look down the
barrel and pull the trigger deal yeah
when I started talking about elevation
relief deal looked at me like I was on I
was up from out of space and just landed
on the UFO
so Isis well the next step is see what
your grenade throwing capabilities are
so took some M26 hand grenades and
unscrewed the fuse and stuff and took it
out
brought them all over and put them in a
in a skirmish line and okay each of them
had a hand grenade okay ready throw them
and the record was four foot
and this thought it was that long yeah
yeah
then I I it hit me well you know
Americans we brought up throwing hand
bought baseballs and footballs yeah you
know transition or throwing a hand
grenade wasn't that and we all thought
we were Roger stallbach indeed so and
then these guys are Hunter together is
you know the only thing they ever threw
in their life is their kids you know and
and was like I have no hand grenades for
these guys they can carry more ammo yeah
but again that's a another classic
example of of Special Forces learning
what the little people can do yeah what
they can't do capabilities capabilities
indeed so uh getting back to Oscar 8 sir
on that day you get back to the team now
you're running point because uh you
hadn't had any of the Deads trained up
well enough you're confident
particularly where you're there in that
situation well another thing too is uh
you know leadership in the jungle as you
know is uh is sought it's looked at when
you're a 1-0 on a team
you're the guy you know right you're you
can't expect anybody else to do not do
what you do
and they look at you you know you're the
Big Kahuna you know you're the guy it's
it's done this and been there
and there was hardly any cover there you
know we're going from one bomb crater to
the other and you know all these B-52
strikes on the on the trail which have
been their previous
oh yeah they oh they bombed they were
bombing that night I was there down oh
God is that right oh yeah
yeah they bombed the trail every night
man sure and they had a specter come
over shooting up the goddamn Trail too
with 105s on her oh no kidding yeah she
went through Specter yeah yeah so anyhow
we you know I says you know we got to
get out of this damn place man this is
this is hazardous to my health you know
I promised my wife I know I didn't have
enough Insurance on me you know to
Parish in Southeast Asia so I I got to
this at the bomb crater and and
in my ER my tail Gunner come running
back and he says
BC vcvc you know and I said
where you point in there's three of them
coming
right behind us you know I said don't
shoot them
I don't know well that worked you know
full automatically yeah about 30 people
opened up on these poor dudes because
the reason why you said no was they
didn't know exactly where you were they
didn't see us right and you wanted
because we were an Obama crater right
you want to keep the low profiles yeah I
just wanted to get out of that damn
place yeah I was one of the helicopters
to come back in and I know how
helicopters are is they're getting shot
at they don't really want to come in
so finally I could I you know of course
musicians give away and everything else
we're in this bomb crater and and Lou
says what are we going to do and I said
we're going to stay right in this damn
bomb credit we're not going anywhere I
said we got some covering concealment in
here put out the Claymores so you know
yeah no deal put out the Claymore is up
in front of us and all of a sudden I you
know I heard these guys are recounting
by fire trying to find them where we're
at and when the Recon by fire they move
shooting into the jungle yeah into the
elephant grass yeah yeah part of it is
to get you to far back at them that way
they know where you're at right another
thing is they're paranoid as we are
you know they're shooting anything that
moves Burrs leeches monkeys monkeys yeah
it's it's like they don't want to die in
Southeast Asia either you know yeah so
we're in this damn and I I had God
wouldn't get a hold of uh yeah who was
on station putting another team in to
the ash out and it was uh Greg it was
Hartness oh is that right yeah recovery
265. yeah the Air Force Captain flying a
no two at that time yeah he was a and
cubby was our was the uh a fact a Ford
air controller yeah but we called him
cubby that was a code name Cody yes sir
he was one of our best cubby Pilots
understanding yeah I think I flew me and
and uh Spider flew him he supported
prairie farm missions yeah that was his
deal he didn't do anything he'd been an
F4 pilot on his first tour there was
that right yeah yeah I forgot it was a
Texas A M Aggie I used to give him
about that well remember he came to the
club he's one of the teams oh yeah he
Blended right in with us yeah great
great okay you couldn't surprise him
he's an Air Force officer it's just so
hard oh yeah yeah yeah he's not one of
them oh we took him to way City where
this inspired her did but anyhow we uh
uh I got him to come come to us and he
said well he says well just I got him on
on a nerk okay sure or tennis or
emergency frequency radio or at the
ultra high yeah VHF right yeah and UHF
uh I got him on a guard freak I went up
on guard sure and told him you know who
who are you and I said this is a prayer
for our emergency and he says I'll be
there
as he always did yes he always did and
anyhow the I see him start circling
above me and he asked me you know where
are you at and I said I'll give you a
shiny so this is our mirror our mirror
and then he'll pick you up exactly where
you were in their bomb create event yeah
he saw well we had no cover in
concealing you know in that place it
looked like you know it looked like
World War One in the trenches there's
nothing bombed out and everything so he
saw us and he says okay he says uh I'll
get uh I'll get the uh
gunships out here and I says
who and he says Scarface you know get
Scarface out here yeah which were in the
Marine gunships awesome caisson and I
also flew a lot of fubai and those guys
were really good absolutely and uh and I
said I told him I said well tell him I'm
a former Marine so get out here real
fast
so and Scarface had been attached as a
couple other Mariners their Aviation was
a tasked Assad throughout the eight-year
secret War yeah damn them in the uh the
cobras out of fubai right from the
forest dude absolutely they were great
yeah and
you know Marine Corps Aviation gets a
lot of because they didn't have the
fancy stuff but those guys you know well
outside of outside of our boy is a judge
in the execution yeah those are 176 but
those helicopters were early ue's they
were B models the B model would really
get off the ground they had fixed fix
m60s on it they didn't have it in the
front yeah yeah and they had a
and we'd have that M5 system with the 40
mic flakes right and I was telling the
story about them coming over and looking
at the cobras these young warrant
officers from the cab yeah of course you
know 19 year old Warren Austin majors
and stuff over there we had Lieutenant
Colonel Robinson yeah Robinson who was
the OIC for that squad for one Squadron
we had working was during 68. yeah and
they we got those yui shot up many times
yeah
yeah that was a bad thing about it but
they lost a bird they were grounded well
um so do we can move on during the day
you're in contact on and off throughout
the day your ammo is running low well
what happened no on this on this
situation was we we never made contact
until we saw these guys
you know I was in snooping poop maze
yeah you know uh basically because when
they shot the helicopter down I think
they thought we didn't get in because
there was one of those you know punching
in punching out and sure
and what happened was you know we ran
into a 37 Mike Mike position well I
forgot about that okay yeah yeah and uh
through some hand grenades in there and
just they're sitting around eating you
neutralized it yeah they were eating
rice and we added to give them some give
them a little
leader dead for it and that shed all
that stuff started blowing up and I
really give her a position away you know
that correct so what I like to do is you
played the cat and mouse game then for
several hours it goes through the day
and then um
uh art getting back to on the ground
again when while RT Lyon fended off
attacks cubby directed airstrike after
air strike at the NBA troops the storage
area the anti-aircraft guns and anything
else he could draw a beat on throughout
the day primary and secondary explosions
follow one after another as the strikes
found their Mark whatever the team's
fate might turn out to be the NBA
repaying the hellacious price for
messing with it yeah we had a uh we had
all kinds of attackers you know you know
I pray for our major emergency sure
those Pilots love to have live targets
you know they're not killing leeches you
know right killing actual stuff and we
started with you know some f4's Marines
even joined in brought their planes in
and uh
then a couple a couple hobos showed up a
couple a1es right showed up and one of
them got all shot up is that right yeah
he uh he was going to bail out and join
us and I said this isn't the place you
want to be
so he decided to try to make it back to
the hang
so yeah it was uh and it then we you
know then they started this they're
going to kill us you know
but then they also had in mind as you
know we're a good bait yes and they love
to shoot helicopters and stuff down you
know sure yeah so I had the feeling they
could overrun us anytime you wanted wow
and uh so this goes on for the whole day
yeah until the evening it was sporadic
and then they started shooting mortars
in on us you can't catch a mortar and
you can't catch a mortar no and two of
my people got wounded for shrapnel and
little people yeah and it got into her
fear deal that you know are we gonna die
here well they brought in the the cab to
pick us up and get us out because
they're the ones that put us push in yes
sir yeah and they had they had their own
gunships right and they got
shot of the man they one of their
gun ships had to crash land and they got
the crew out door gunning was killed
well and so it was kind of like well
it's getting dark in this
dinner time we gotta go
well at that point you got the good news
that a king bee wasn't real no that what
happened was
I was starting to panic and you know we
can't survive tonight here do we they're
going to kill us
so I was almost in a situation
that we're going to take as many of them
as we can and you know sure
and maybe they'll give me a bronze star
with dude for dying maybe maybe and and
Greg says
I got I got one helicopter coming can
you get everybody on it
and I said I'll ride on the goddamn door
handle if you if you get it in here and
that's when the king bee came in and he
had to Scarface with him right so
Scarface would make a gun run and then
the king bee which was pilot by captain
on yeah which we learned years later was
him yeah and he came in and uh had no
co-pilot no copilot yeah and which of
course and he was waving at me
yeah because we had the kingb pause that
we knew each other because from being oh
yeah I knew him from uh cam duck he used
to come in and support us up again when
you were doing some training then too so
that would be part of the routine where
you can't talk if you weren't running
missions you're doing training yeah
absolutely we used to do the mcquiry
crap you know before it got Stables day
1A strap fit under your butt and snappy
on a snapped me but anyhow yeah he he
came in and the goddamn Marines were
just shooting up the damn place yeah
saved our butts really and uh I'll never
forget that we he landed that helicopter
and he had a door gunner had those old
A6 30 calibers yeah and they kept
jamming
yeah and I was afraid he was going to
shoot us getting on the goddamn bird you
know the barrel that thing was swinging
all over the place he was
so I got I got everybody you know we
always had that deal when you got ready
to leave you pop smoke yeah yeah that
way they know you got everybody on it
and I was I'm sitting in there and I
could hear the goddamn bullets hitting
the thing coming through you know lights
coming through the plane because they're
shooting
he's shooting the helicopter up and I
looked I looked up there and and ons is
up there and he looks down at me and he
goes like this oh my god oh that's so
cool
well and also you guys were in in the uh
still in the concrete at that point yeah
we blew the claim all your claims yeah
they charged us and then we blew to
Claymores and
you know I don't you know you heard
screams and stuff I sure wouldn't have
to making body count you know oh yeah of
course they always ask you to Homer did
you kill yeah you know Baker's stuff a
little bit yeah
sarcastic Watkins well let me just get
back to the book for a second because
this is that one of those classic scenes
where the whole scene bordered on
surrealistic what would the LZ lit by
flickering brushfire the sounds of
gunfire explosions the smell of cordite
and burned human flesh and this
improbable savior hovering above which
was the h-34 kingb piloted by captain on
yeah I'd been fertilizer in Southeast
Asia it hadn't been for him oh yeah
absolutely and uh this was last Light I
mean there were nobody else coming yeah
and there was that one point you're in
the bomb creator and
um
when the king be touched down a later
well now I'm sorry let me get back to
one more spot here because you were Lily
and a bomb creator and he brought the
king bee into the bomb cream oh yeah
right and then he was able to get close
to the ledge or the edge of that crater
you could get your people into the kingb
nobody wanted to get it up on that ledge
because
it'd be fired yeah we were throwing
these little people into me and me and
Lou yeah and Luke
kept looking at me when's my turn you
know kind of deal yeah and so it's like
the king bee it settled into a
stationary hover its front wheels placed
delicately inside the crater and there
it sat and unbelievable Vision a heroic
portrait of an old Warrior taking a
pounding but refusing to falter yeah
those those sikorskis would take some
hits they couldn't it had been a huey
had been shot down oh yeah and there I
mean it's like it feels like a mother
hen
hovering over a nest but you guys jump
on it it seemed like now this is my way
out of this goddamn place
and then could you tell that the drama
didn't end you're on a helicopter he
lists off and as you're leaving he had
the jute to get around anti-aircraft
yeah we're also taking 12.7 whoa which
is the equipment I didn't realize it
they moved it in on us oh is that right
yeah they wanted to shoot helicopters
down
whoa that's what is and then I found out
later well here and I'll tell you later
when I get back to the Applebee three
you know typical debriefing you know oh
yeah
and uh but it was Jax of all people so
anyhow we get on we get on the bird of
course or all of us have wet our pants
and
that crap you know we're gonna die here
all the time all the way back to Cason
we're getting triple A Fire and it
was just it was like a World War II
movie Just Puffs in the sky and and
stuff and he's you know Hans hit the top
of trees we're low level and you know
trying to get out of the
the area and then the Scarface followers
all the way back to caisson
and then landed a case on course we
we jump off the damn thing and then you
know every time they seen a bird come in
they start shooting right so we had
artillery you know we're back home and
we're getting shot at again
and so we all run for day doors of
a trench line there we are in for the
trench line
and they're coming down they come and
got me and allowed me to come into the
talk
to God's country you know oh my God wipe
your feet before you come in you know
yeah absolutely and I get in there and
and of course they they've been
monitoring all this stuff on the radio
they knew we were
oh yeah because the the NBA had very
good FM rdf radio Direction five yeah
and they monitored it yeah when I flew
coverage did you get any jamming like
Lynn black had no no
I tell you the truth we were on uh we
ended up being on our irks all the time
because we're we started with you know
with the deal with getting a hold of uh
Hartness right on the on their 10. and
well we were you know everything we were
doing we were talking to our cubby
you know and he was he was running the
show
now the aircraft you know support stuff
so we were talking on Eric 10 with them
that PRC 77 and 25 right you know it was
on it was uh not usable really because
it was easier for him to talk on the
guard freak which they fly on all the
time on on that three uh three four
three point eight uh freak UHF free
right and uh it was easier for him to
talk on that and then trying to go over
to FM
which was the
which was the 77 so we basically were
doing all this stuff when it works
well so at caisson
you and the teams would train but
occasionally you would leave the base to
go fishing
no I never did that no well your team
left one time well they used to the
hunter-gatherer crap you know they go
out
we're really Mountain yards and we live
off the elements yeah they all worked in
that Tea Plantation in France the one
the one time I'm thinking about you're a
caisson your team goes out they hunt
they gather and you come back the next
day the Marine Corps went out and got
hammered oh that was no that was that's
when we were out in that we started
taking mortar fire
from the old village the old French
Villa right down there with the French
Plantation was in bed again this is the
case on Village which yeah not to be
confused with the American caisson no no
no no this is the old this is where the
original case on a team was at right 40
went to Long Bay they were in that area
yes sir that's you know that's uh Again
part of that history of that time yeah
people they've been there Seas we'd had
an 18 there since 65. oh is that right
yeah oh yeah
you know the Marines think they were the
first ones there huh no and even Ray
califo has a special time at the caisson
Village when he was there with his uh
with his uh America yeah he was a cam
duck too during was that right yeah he
was there during the seeds America but
your team went out did you get mortared
while you're out no what happened was
they came
I had to but like you know here I am I
got the damn field phone in my bunker
right because I was on the very end of
the bunker line yeah and if anybody they
want to talk to somebody we had to go
find them down the bunker line
people I didn't even know because you
know there was not a lot of
fraternization going on yeah sure we
lived in this little world of sea
rations and rats you know but the the
point I want to get to would be your
team went out and came back the next day
Marines went out and got hammered and
here's what happened and they had a pow
no yeah no this is how it
really happened yes we they called me
then to Bunker and a team next to me
Percy Hudson who was a friend of mine
we'd served with Fred on his sixth group
together
and he was he was the seven I don't know
77 guy he'd been around a long time he's
starting first class okay right and and
yeah they call it and he was the devil
before with me they called me and him
the phone rings says you know you and
Hudson come up here well I knew it was
you know they didn't want us to come up
there to rearrange the deck chairs yeah
right and this is you know this is a
mission so he can get up there and if
people don't realize it you know this
crap we'd run in country missions and
like nothing you know yeah the war is
being fought
it was like yeah
yeah yeah
compared to pray yeah we can walk back
to the Hamptons
so any other places well we're taking 81
millimeter mortars and the Marines are
from the village
well what else is new we're taking fire
all over the damn place and they says we
need you guys to go down there and check
it out
and there's not a tree in sight there
you know there's no cover and Highway
nines running right there
so
Jax was the operations officer and he
says what's your plan and I looked at
him and I said to survive and he said
well you goddamn wise ass walking you
know well that's accurate yeah I qualify
you know yeah it did in the first place
he didn't want to piss me off so because
I was running missions it's uh Eddie I
got back with Percy and I says okay and
we had to go out the front gate like it
was yeah I mean and walk down highway
nine I mean the Marines got ambushed on
this damn Highway every day you know
they go down to what what you know with
those 48 tanks like we can't say I had
Charlie had run out and hit it
with RPGs you know
so so you go down to yourself I I split
I'm in charge and yeah right it should
have been Hudson he can't even seen with
me but I was the mission guy
so I I put him on one side of the road
and I'm on the other and I just get us
in the wedge yeah yeah and combat wedge
and I says okay
I tell this is where Bingo was there I
told Bingo look at if we take far here's
what we're going to do
we get our asses back in the face
ASAP if not sooner you have your running
shoes on
we're not going to get enough because
the Marines go down to our company man
and this is this is during the case on
scene oh yeah yeah we're still and
they're worried about a couple mortar
rounds coming in because it came close
but I'd like to get back to the moment
will you finally good what happened what
happened was yeah we go down there and
not one round farted we hit the village
and I said okay retrograde you know sure
yeah just get back you didn't find
anything well I didn't look that hard
yeah I wasn't going to say that he was
kind of like looks okay to me
so anyhow we get back to the to the to
the base like and I go down there
personally says well you go I've already
been so I go down there and said well I
couldn't find anything so you're back in
base
up so the next day right the Marines had
this road clearing operation they used
to go to the rock pile which was a
marine Outpost right the road and how
those guys are getting their asses shot
at too and they had a company of Marines
they had one Los Altos with the 106s
mounted on it yeah with three 106's on
each side I mean they fired all of them
one time damn thing would turn over and
nobody wanted those damn things that are
in the Army designed them to give it to
the Marines oh no yeah okay and they had
an M48 tank right right and then they
had two
two deuce and ass full of troops yeah
they got hammered well they would they
use the Anto as the point man and and
the M48 tank behind it and then these
guys are in their trucks
well this is patent yeah this is Indian
Country out there you know
so we're up on watching them go down I
got pictures of this I take a look I
have my pin double e 13 oh no kidding
yeah okay I'll send you the pictures
anyhow they start down the road and they
get they clear our compound
and all of a sudden man the World opened
up we're taking rounds into our compound
all those guys are dumping in the
Marines are getting hammered on them
they got they well they they come out
with RPGs they hit the tank of course we
didn't have reactive armor like they got
today they hit that damn tank and uh it
was smoking it it wasn't you know it
came down the road 100 miles an hour I
never knew attack could go that fast
backwards and they knocked the antos out
they killed everybody the two kids in
the hospital they killed them and then
the Marines all got out and got into a
world of crap with them and you're a
battle going on we're all down in our
bunkers you know God damn yeah flak
jackets over our head you know and all
this craps coming in and the tank stops
right in front of my compound they
pulled this one kid out he was all
screwed up on
shot up from the shrapnel coming in from
the RPG because those are you know those
days it's a shape charge yes so it would
you know yeah RPG or rocket propelled
grenade yeah they got sevens now it was
RPG twos in these days but anyhow that
was her and I that was their you know
their law or whatever now sure we call
and they were really good I wished we'd
had them they were really good weapons
and they knocked the tank out man the
only thing still running was the engine
to hit the turret was the homogeneous
Steels the lightest in their terrain
because it's condemned and uh
and then one of the deuce and a half
come back and the driver
was all shot up and his co-driver was
dead
and you know all this craps going on and
finally it you know it ceased and all
the guys came back and they had 27
wounded and 14 killed
and it uh they I get this call
from the talk for me to come to the talk
country
you know the old one deck is the same
Marine Corps anyhow
you know where they actually had food
so I go down there to to and they got to
we had this Arvin Ranger uh uh Captain
it was attached to us uh you know you
got to have a be amazing right sure and
he and he was a good guy he he was there
and he saw me and he said come here you
know they had this NBA
Captain right they had him and a chair
in there
the Marines had captured him again you
know they'd kill a bunch of NBA too sure
Marines are going to come back unless
they you're surprised they had an
officer alive
well what shocked me was why in the hell
am I here you know yeah I you know you
got to be with me speakers here all I
know is goddamn DD mow mow and
uh so anyhow
[Music]
yeah bars in there yeah and he says
Pat you got to hear this and this guy
looked up at me this NBA and he says
searching and they're all laughing it
means they're all laughing I said what
the first I come is there's a comedy
club you know yeah what's going on here
well what they they weren't in the
Ambush site dug in
and we'd walk right through it
they were all under it was like the
Japanese in World War II you know oh
yeah sure you know camouflage stuff and
uh we skirted uh the Amber site they
were on both sides of the road and uh
Percy was on one side and all of a
sudden he had a record right too and
they he said the only reason he didn't
they didn't want to kill a bunches
he had three Americans hit a bunch of
mountain yards they could do that
anytime they want they wanted to kill
them they wanted to kill Marines whoa
yeah so that would that was that also is
a reflection of the of the enemy
dedicated oh they don't want to go for
Mass casualties and they ain't they they
didn't Panic okay stayed right in that
position yeah and you weren't even aware
of them they were that well I was aware
of them I made Jesse Owens looked like a
punk man we've been
going in there we wasn't a crypt to take
this was a in a reinforced company
sure yeah so um
by June your time at fob 3 ends you get
transferred to fob 1 fubai
that's where we meet for the first time
you come down there and you came solo
without a team or with the team well
what happened was Oscar 8 right right
they sent me they landed a blackbird a
caisson
get me out right so you had to go down
for the Deep yeah I had to go to to
khaki land in Saigon and on on pasture
street where the embassy was we're we're
house 10 is yeah and SOG headquarters
yeah and of course I walked in there and
had a bath and you know shower in three
months it was red clay good I looked
like it in America from the case yeah I
looked like an American Indian coming in
there and hadn't had a haircut of course
yeah that could have been one of the
best go to headquarters and you have to
read them about what you saw well they
landed at Blackbird where it has a
Fulton recovery system on them yeah yeah
they landed and they of course they they
just swing the thing around and I was up
there the Marines had a uh air control
thing they already had a what they call
uh you know anglico a maroon's called
anglico it was they had their own they
did their own of course they had their
own Aviation did their own right traffic
control so I was over there and they
said the plane's coming in get ready
so I got you know my rucksack I just got
out of the boomies and then you know I
was still trying to drink water and
they you know they'd Squirtle debrief me
a case on and Lou finished it up and I
just they just told me you're going to
Saigon and I said well I'm ready for RNR
that's what I'm giving me yeah
so any other see she went 30 lands and
it's out in the strip of course they
guys in Laos see that and they start hmm
they open fire of course they do yeah
and I'm running down the heirs trip
trying to get on the tailgate
and a load Masters back there he was
going like this to me come on come on so
I throw my rucksack on and and I grabbed
my rucksack and the guy finally pulls me
up just they were lifted off man and I
was whoa I was thinking I forgot that
part
hyperventilating and they dragged me
back at aircraft and this kid looked at
me like I was somebody out of a science
fiction movie you know oh yeah yeah okay
but and again even when you're
debriefing you you ran into the same
thing that the troll George Sternberg
and Mike Tucker ran into after they
reported uh seeing tank tracks reporting
it in a nasty saw a tank
well they searched before before the
disease was hit I land I landed uh at
Thompson right and they got a Navy SEAL
out there to pick me up it was part of
the Detachment here right it's out there
in a gray Jeep so I knew it was Navy
right
so all right Kevin he looks at me and
he's a good god Sarge where are you from
I said it's classified I can't tell you
any kind of looked every woman in the
project not my project yes
he takes me to house 10.
right and well not the headquarters no
oh tiles 10. guess this is that's our
safe house in Saigon yeah it's in the
evening sorry guys I'm gonna uh cut real
quick yeah
move your chair just think more facing
uh towards Pat sure whenever we post
this thing it gets uh static it cuts out
a little bit so if we could just
um
just kind of we don't even have to move
it we just gotta turn it turn
of that light
how's that that's perfect that way your
shoulder's not hitting that yeah I hit
it I tried to avoid it but no no worries
it's just the way you receive it it's
hard not to when you've got all this
time on TV you're not look how well I'm
doing this and I'm a novice yeah but
you're you're the sergeant major
we've retrained you five times you think
you learned this by now
yeah I was gonna since I could I was
going to tell them uh you know they
picked me up and they put me in and
weasel Taylor was Sergeant Major there I
knew him I was seven he's in a typical
and I walk in with you know all my low
burying equipment on yeah hanger and
he's handling all these kids are looking
at me they've never seen him no no this
is a this is one of those guys they
write books about so he he said he sat
there look at he said they're looking at
me and he says
Sergeant Watkins and I say yes sir major
we're going to get you in a clean
uniform
and take a shower and uh
you go over and get debrief and I said
no I'm going to go just like I am
sergeant
he looked at me and he says don't you
want to look professional I said I
thought I did look professional I said
I'm above the average a case
he funny here he looked at me like
you're saying go to work
so uh uh Pat you were you were going to
house 10 right
yeah but so so anyway you go to house 10
that's our Top Secret Safe House in
Saigon yes and it's an upgrade from my
house too too indeed yeah they had a
they had
caught on their eating areas and stuff
they had you know the forks and knives
and lined up and had tablecloths like a
regular restaurant yeah I was like I
thought I was you know I was in San
Francisco with it you know and
everybody's wearing khakis yeah so when
you're there you're approached by a
sergeant major who should remain
nameless yeah he says bass says hey Pat
get cleaned up before you go for your
debriefing and what was your response
Sarge well you know of course I'm sure I
wasn't acceptable for for you know for
Good Company indeed but uh he says well
we'll get you can take a shower and
we'll get you in a clean uniform and it
says no I'm going like this and he
looked at me this weekend go like this
and I'm going like this he looked at me
I must have had that 20 000 mile stair
in my eye like and you still had your
car 15 yeah don't with this gun
yeah you know this this is not smart you
know he's like he's he's loved it
becoming the serial killer of gardening
house 10. but anyways you wind up for
your debriefing I just like I don't want
to spend too much time but even there
when you first reported what you had
seen observed directly for over three
hours how was that received well the big
thing was I come I come in there and
you've been in that debriefing room and
they got the situation Maps right up on
the wall and it was like remember those
light bright kits you used to have as a
kid used to stick to things oh yeah yeah
they had these in the map up there and I
you know being an Intel Sergeant I
started looking at this thing and it's I
look up uh you know the AO I just come
out of and they you know there's this
light green eyes and I go down the index
and I said known truck part
in other words and the aircraft position
all this Intel well my target folder was
sterile
oh no typical crap it's like they don't
want you to know this stuff because you
won't go there you know they want you to
wander in there and bring air strikes
initiative some sitting there looking at
and it's like kernels debrief me he says
uh Sergeant Watkins he says I noticed
you're looking at the situation man and
I say yeah sorry I'm sir
he said you know that's all top secret
and I says yeah I figured that out my
target folders didn't have any of this I
didn't know what to say
[Laughter]
just in singular he walks in you know oh
is that right then Colonel Jack's JK
sing along yeah a single ABS there and
he's got Kavanaugh with him he was
changing all over sure I didn't you know
I knew single app only by reputation
I've seen him one time right and you
know I didn't know Kevin and just for
the record for anybody or listeners John
K singlob at the time was a colonel he
was in the OSS during World War II
Jeb and then uh judberg teams and he had
jumped into France Behind Enemy Lines
Belgium and then he jumped into uh China
or Manchuria Manchuria he'd win well
well World War II this is all it says he
flipped he flipped he went from he went
from Europe to Southeast Asia you know
right and I was working with John Kai
Shack yes and then uh during the Korean
War he was a spec ops there's a jack
program yeah and then he made Major
General
yeah
many years later yeah he got relieved of
command that's a long story versus
Carter president Carter because Jack
singing Love was truthful or Jack wanted
to tell him why the war really was yeah
and that Navy officer did want to hear
it indeed so uh on that day Jack is
there and the part of the transition
because he had been the officer in
charge of SOG for over two years two
years and Colonel Kavanaugh was yeah you
know they had their families the Clark
Air Base you're right I didn't know that
I didn't know what he is not then yeah
but we know it now yeah only know it now
so you're there for the debriefing and
walks good then Colonel John K singlob
yeah
call to attention I looked around like
well that draws fire
so anyhow you're they're going through
this thing and I you know they they
started to thank you of course that's
what really you know
mechanized stuff and that really excites
them you know oh yeah it's kind of of
course there's with trolls the pt-76 is
the amphibious tanks that right they
brought into Long Bay that's what they
saw but you saw the t-34 I saw t-34s the
old there was a World War II tanks was
that right oh yeah they used the
Russians used at in the Ukraine and
stuff you know that was their main back
in those days yeah that was their main
main battle tank okay tell you the truth
they were better than than the patent
tanks we had
because they had a bigger gun on it
right because they you know we had
those guys
the patent tanks that we had we just
produced them because we've won a lot of
them out there Sherman tanks yeah the
Shermans yes sir and what happened was
they uh
you know Germans went for quality not
quantity right and since they so
returning to your Assad debriefing you
told them and was there any other
questions or well what happened was you
know I told him we'd laid up on the road
to look at me like maybe how to give
this guy a sobriety test right yeah
and I'll never forget single app says uh
I I heard you got some good Intel and I
said well I I think it's good sir I
guess yeah you know I I think it's
timely you know deal that too the only
Intel deal it's just timely critical in
other words you know this should be
passed on sure to to Anderson Air Force
Base and then Cadena were the big planes
go you know yeah we're to refer to the
B-52s yeah yeah so he says
that's already been done Sergeant really
yeah so I knew it yeah they were
actually interested in some people wants
that that I had done yeah and so Annie
has a debriefing went on and they
basically says okay you go back to house
10. we'll feed you so I went back there
and Don Carr was there
you know Captain Carr was
you know Carr he said he was that long
he was Dave Carr yeah well I knew a Dave
Carr well Don oh the one who was okay
nkp yes could he have been a ccs and
then went to nkp he'd been in the sixth
group he was good friends with Mike
Taylor yeah yeah they were they were CCS
together in JP well anyhow Don was there
oh is that right yeah he was trying to
get inside you know or CNC sure
and I knew him in the sixth group and
when he was a lieutenant and he's a good
guy you know
and uh he's deeper and I said well you
don't want to go where I'm going I'm
going back to Jason
he looked at me and he said well you
guys are the ones doing every damn thing
I'm sick and tired of being the escort
officer you know that kind of crap so he
wiggled his way to CCS yeah and and and
I you know
I had one beer and it knocked me on my
butt and I went to bed yeah well middle
of the night there's a pounding on my
door and I dropped up looking for
my car 15. you know I'm still
understanding WTF yeah I'm Siege
mentality still man absolutely and uh
don't go over and opened up the door and
this kid's standing there with a
clipboard he says sir sir
I have my underwear and stuff he says
what's your name Ryan conserial number
and I looked at him and said what the
you need that for
he said well we just took in some mortar
rounds down the street and stuff in the
more and sergeant major sent me up here
to get names of people from before we
can put them in for a CIB oh no oh
the door and a CIB was a combat infantry
bill which you earned from being in
contact combat with the Enemy yes not
just getting more just dropped right of
course these guys are all in search of
some identity to go back to brag looking
like they were so uh at this point in
your career uh you've transferred to
fubai and maybe this would be the point
where we flipped well I kept that bad
deported I came back I got on a block
right but we get back to case on I know
high fly in I fly into janaang right or
Blackbird do you want me to jump on a
Blackberry I get there and I hitchhike a
ride
therefore before
the Airfield which is like 10 miles away
yeah from the air Big Air Base there's
more aircraft landing near a name place
in the world at that time yes sir so
anyhow I get I get back to the base and
you know how the security was in that
damn place you know God it was like a
beach party to you and uh I walked down
there and I walked to the talk and uh
and and
sergeant major uh
got into the talk and sergeant major uh
God he got killed in 2030 was a case on
before uh oh yeah I'll think of his name
anyhow he saw me and of course he knew I
was a case on when the I says it's our
major I need to get a lift the case on
and he says well if you go there you're
going to be there by yourself
what
he says they moved out everybody did the
Marines left left and left if we'll be
three to everybody in bar I guess he
told me later he said the Marines just
left us we're just he says I couldn't
get anybody to make a decision and then
he said I finally I said well that's
nice Colonel you finally made a decision
so
he got birds and stuff in there
and they packed up everything left here
so that's how I ended up in food F will
be one yeah I got the food and the
sergeant major with sergeant major P
Graham Pedro Pedro yeah he got killed on
23rd August 23rd we'll get to that a
little bit later
yeah that's a whole day's process anyhow
he uh I got I got the fob one and it
goes Barr wanted me there yeah so I got
there and I said oh God they're gonna
put me on a reconquin yeah going to be
an ass y'all that's a little he hadn't
been there in a couple weeks yeah I was
like God I just got out of case on now
I'm going to ashaw Valley and also in
the 101st can't even stay in this damn
place maybe before we talk about your
history entering how you entered service
to our country was before you go to
Kason and after you left that for before
you spent a little time TDY at fob 2 and
Contin well they sent five teams of us
up there yeah and during that time
that's where Villa Rosa got killed right
so
um in January when Villa Rose was killed
it was in a target from fob2 that was we
went up there to support well we didn't
have our target areas it was cam duck
right we were supposed to run that
backside of the ass shell the cam duck
and it was a rainy season and you
couldn't get in or not sure so they
decided well we've got all these Warm
Bodies around
you know and these guys that
fob2 are getting killed and everything
else unless some some of these people up
here to get killed
so they took the five what they
considered operational teams and I only
had a 1-1 I had no radio operator my
radio operator quit on me and went 2018.
I don't know if it's my personality or
are you just scared
but I just had Bill Reasoner a young
spec four with my 1-1 and so they sent
Belarus to Ron Brown Boudreau
[Music]
Out Boy was part of that boy asked Boyer
was unassed with Ron Brown yeah Boyer
and before they went M.I.A well they
were my backup team my decade out of nkp
that's all they got right with the
elephant deal
yeah that's one well we got to get to
the elephant deal so you this is on a
mission out of contou by this time was
they sent the five team no he was on he
was on the Anaconda with Charlie Wilcox
he was a radio operator right and I uh I
got there and I said well they
can't put me in I only got one American
you know so they saw that they sent me
to Cambodia
on Detroit border area with a team five
of us me and me that was the deal on
those days all five Americans no no no
no five total three in didge and me and
Reasoner oh wow yeah okay yeah five Warm
Bodies yeah and that was a that was a
deal you know couldn't take Minds you
couldn't take him seven that's where
they saw it off so again we got to
clarify for our for our audience that
the Rules of Engagement for SOG in
Cambodia in 1960 was dramatically
different from Prairie Fire which was
Laos and in Cambodia you couldn't have
fast air no no close air support from A1
Sky readers only thing you have with
helicopter gunships period and a Bible a
good Bible Gideon Bible so in this case
you got a five-man team you and your one
one you go into this Target in Cambodia
let's get to how this was chosen you
know you were chosen yeah Chosen One The
Chosen One indeed together I get got the
call from there of course I ran into
Fred there he said yeah Fred sabotage
yeah and then we were on the same at
that time your books yes youngster yeah
yeah we were both he'd had a tour of
Duty over on a team he'd been on the uh
on the uh a team outside of a long day
it's been that long bay but uh
on the uh trying Valley operation holy I
drive yeah he was on that 18. because
they were doing a radio operator and for
again for our listeners uh viewers we
had the I drank Valley which was the
first major contact between the first
Cav American conventional units and the
NBA pure helicopter unit indeed and they
had to attach the whole Air Wing
division which was helicopters and what
started that conference that battle was
an a camp that had been on the scene and
they brought Delta Force in that's where
Chuck that's where charging Charlie
uh Beckwith got shot and he got shot
indeed yeah Don De Beer was a good
friend of mine got shot at the same time
he said I never see anybody cry so much
in my life oh no but again Delta Force
then was a quick reaction yeah
we know it today yeah they were in
Countryside indeed they did outstanding
oh yeah I'd like to be near that in a
nice club and everything really nice
club oh yeah but anyway so you finally
get inserted into Cambodia or five yeah
what happened you're in some elephant no
no this is come on this is really really
good
I go over and they tell me this and I
didn't know what the rules were we were
trained for Prairie for us sure right I
didn't know what the rules were and they
start telling me Demarcus a queenberry
rules for Cambodia you know well you
can't take any Claymores you can't take
no Claymore oh no no because we were
down there in November 60 we had
claiming oh yeah they started well this
was all that deal with Chinook with uh
Nook yeah you know the Lettermen the
country and let him have his Villa in
Paris and stuff you know you know we
could go in and do this stuff
and you know like you said no Tactical
Air Support you know only gun chips
um no King bees they wouldn't let King
bees in there so it was all All-American
yeah and uh you know you could know him
70. they they kept telling me the stuff
I couldn't take and I almost said well
can I take my car 15 with me you know if
I you couldn't wear any American clothes
yet of stuff sterile fatigue yeah yeah
no no dog tags no none are just crap you
know
so make a long story short you know I'll
go doctoral and they put me on the
helicopter me and the doctor's alarm
and tripod yeah and they had they see
there were guys from CCS there um mad
dog was there sure yeah they were
running the tri-border areas there today
so those guys were it was kind of like
well one day ago this is their target
area but no walking you only got one guy
so you stop thinking just get up yeah
it's kind of like your past your pay
grade thinking they're staff sergeants
yeah they give me we fly right over this
damn Village I could have really yes I
could have spit at him and and get to
the LZ and they dropped me I didn't know
all I knew was I was in Southeast Asia
and I had no idea
and reasoners are looking at me like
you're my adult leadership and you look
a little confused a little
yeah I'm trying I got the map out I'm
trying to get a fix I had no idea you
know there was no GPS babe and uh so I I
decided man I can't sit here and screw
around with this stuff you know I gotta
move yeah so I get up on this hill
Ridgeline well you know we're in
Cambodia but this is just like Laos it's
just land that's continue with a damn
border on it and
we're scooting along and all of a sudden
pickup trackers immediately they start
beating bamboo and shooting the rifles
right then my pucker Factor went up to
10. you know I was just a seven before
but now I'm ten yeah and bridging on 10
plus yes so I knew I I was in the world
of they knew I was in there of
course how wouldn't they I flew over
there yeah
yeah okay so you're on you're not a
helicopter Pilots or get these guys off
my bird how do I get shot so so anyhow I
decide
I'm not going to lead this LZ because I
know they could put a helicopter in here
yeah I don't have to search around so I
I looped on my back Trail Right and
started and I look up and here comes
three dudes diddly bopping down a trail
down there you had khakis on yeah pit
helmets
and
and it's my first time I ever seen it
you know yeah at BC up close yeah right
this is like February January February
yes February February okay yes February
19th oh the same day of Fred Savage this
is the continuous whoa this is this is
the big deal and Fred went in the same
he was a doctor at the same time I was
right getting ready to go in a very far
and at that time I guess it was assigned
to fob2 at cartoon yeah he was a 1-0
yeah he was going into Hotel night Hotel
nine yeah whoa that was one of it
which five days later I was in indeed so
anyhow
these three come diddly bopping down the
trail
and I looked at my people
yeah yeah and so they're looking down
looking around you know they're looking
for Footprints and like I you know I
wasn't going to well I'm not a trail
Walker you know I know
that's a golden rule stay up the trails
yeah walk the trail and die you know so
yeah so they're looking around all of a
sudden this one looks down there and I
said they said oh my God I grease
all three of them then everybody starts
shooting you know and uh Reasoner I look
up a reason or he hadn't shot one round
miles was open it's still cold and I
looked underneath and there were two
magazines laying on the ground he had
ejected a magazine
that's the first time he'd ever been
yeah been fired at but he rebounded oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah he was all he needed
was a wake-up call so
anyhow I says man we got to get the DLC
so I get on I get it on the phone and I
there's no such thing as a prayer for
our emergency again Cambodia and Daniel
Boone that was Daniel Boone in those
days and I get on to the back and tell
him I'm in oral and he says well get get
high and dry you know
because because there's a team over
getting the world of he was Fred
yeah and
you know this and I says
now your body I started I I was in close
to panic mode that uh are you going to
come and get me better today you know
the subway our am I the second choice on
the subway system and you know what the
hell is going on here of course I don't
know what's going on yeah Fred and
facility he finally decides I says I
need tack Aaron he said we can't do it
and I said well he says unless you're in
Laos I said
looks like laughs
so he brought a new one here he dropped
me but I got in trouble over that too of
course I didn't give a what he
could do Court martial yeah so and the
cover pilot he was he was good you know
this guy he didn't have a writer with
him he was just because it was just you
and the Air Force yeah it was the the
other writer was over with Fred sure and
uh so any anyhow they get a helicopter
in a big long story short you know we
get the hell out of the place and they
take me back to Doctor at the grassy
area there and dropped me off and I
looked across and there's five King bees
lined up on the other side and all these
goddamn guys are running around
and I told Reasoner I says
man what's going on I so I go over and
and uh Howard's there right yeah
supplies are gone yeah Robert Howard
what is goddamn mini 14 and yeah you
know this and uh
he's in in Dallas long streets there
Dallas was there yeah Dallas is there
and
so anyhow and a bunch of guys Pappy Webb
was there all these killers from sub
Dallas you know Dallas is like me you're
trying to survive yeah all these guys
are there and they got Mountain yards
you know it was a mic Force I mean Mike
force it was a Hatcher Force right and
they were going in to get Fred
yeah you could just put a record on that
Fred had gone in on a bright light after
team was hit then the helicopter gets
shot down and then while he's on the
ground another one gets shot down he
pulled people out he was in there he was
in there the one he was getting inserted
or distracted they were getting out
right okay because they got in the world
of crap and trying to find that you know
it was a bright light trying to get
right there's two guys could kill him up
on cartoon yeah and uh
he got on the helicopter on the Huey and
they they just got up to Harvard speed
and they hit him with an RPG
and it broke the boom off oh and started
spinning and it threw Fred out
and what happened was he got on he got
on the he got on the ground and the bird
crashed and caught on fire from the fuel
jp4 sure yeah
so he ran to the helicopter
fell down because he had a concussion he
knew he was screwed up and this is what
Fred told me later back at Bragg years
years later when he was getting the
medal well so anyhow he's he says I got
up and he says the compartment was all
on fire
and magnesium was concerned and he
pulled the co-pilot out
and Nicole pilot was dead
and he then he went back and got he got
the pilot and the pilot was all screwed
up and he was all in his harness locked
in and Fred didn't know how to get the
harness off and he's going through all
this and finally he works him loose and
Frets getting burnt too sure from the
Magnesium then the rounds start going
off on all the guys yeah the rounds and
helicopter cooking off yeah it was on
the guys they were burning up and
they're called their load very nice of
course they're all they were screaming
and everything and you know Fred told me
yet he you know he was suffering he you
know he had PTSD back all severe and uh
so anyhow he pulled
pile it over and he went back trying to
get Glover because Glover was going to
take the team over was that right yeah
Fred was going to uh go into operations
and for a strata team right
so anyhow make a long story short they
got Fred out and taken back to play cool
at the hospital there and
the story was
uh of course I I ran the hotel nine
Mission uh five days later five days
later our 23rd went off
I got conned into that deal
I I was a glut I was like you man I was
a glutton for punishment yes I mean my
wife would have killed me and she and if
they didn't kill me she would have known
the I did indeed yes
and put a shoe up my butt so anyhow I I
heard the story that
they were putting Fred in for a silver
star
typical right wow
the aviation unit the 57th Aviation unit
their Commander this Colonel had a bit
that Fred had done this saved his Pilot
went back and got you know got the body
underground yeah and did all this
and he basically towed CNC if you put
him in for a silver star we're gonna up
that to the metal model
and that's how Fred got the medal no
kidding
man one was behind the scenes stories no
yeah and Fred told me that yeah
and so Fred gets so he earned the Medal
of Honor on that day February 19 1968.
yeah I got an Arkham with the same day
we got the V they put he gave you a V2
the only reason I was a cartoon if I'd
been an apple before I would have got a
Good Conduct metal maybe maybe yeah yeah
so it was Hotel so five days later
you're in hotel now nine which is one of
the most notorious targets for the
continent will be two there's another
story leading up to that my alligator
mouth overloaded my Mockingbird
as I got into the club you know all of
us telling our war stories and Anaconda
that shop was a radio operator yeah
right and Bob Doherty was one one and
and Charlie Wilcox who
he was a motor Sergeant 80 Deuce well
good good guy but he was over his head I
shouldn't be dead of the dead because I
had to go into recover his body laying
around oh pecan Camp duck deal right so
anyhow
they they basically found out they were
going into the start and we didn't know
what the targets were there you know I
was they were just in Southeast
Asia I didn't know yeah what these
designators were now how notorious it
was and said they were going into Hotel
nine well I knew that's where Fred got
in a world of
you know I said well what oh and they
ran these same damn targets well they
wanted to put the airstrikes in and
there was We were supposed to be a a
they were going to put a hatch of force
in and they had two Recon teams they're
going to parallel them and they're going
to go down the highway 110. really yeah
and shoot they had they had taken two uh
57 cordless rifles and they're going to
shoot trucks yeah right like Charlie's
gonna let you shoot trucks
so anyhow I get over to him and I
volunteered for this thing and I said
well they'll never let me go because
it's a full team and in the
S3 over and it's saying oh we don't give
a how many guys remember before
going you could take home we don't care
no yeah so they come Charlie comes back
and says well you can go
this was a Rouge I was supposed to do
this
so shots are excited because his buddy's
going to go with him right yeah so I
said well can I take any indigen he said
yeah so I'll go back over and I get two
volunteer tie you my zero one and ER
uh Eddie how I had a so-called uh numb
team yeah a bunch of troll on Cowboys
you know but they're good yeah it's they
were okay after a trained them they came
out no I was the first
that was the original it was a girl no
kidding oh yeah we were all these guys
the CIA had recruited and brought them
in you know right and we were the
trainers they didn't need your training
ourselves you know yeah and uh anyhow
make a horror story short I got to tell
you looked at me like what did you
follow Jeremy
so when we get on we you know we get we
go into helicopters I'm the second one
and shops in the first one uh with uh
Wilcox and I Dougherty's with me and we
we land on this LZ and I get out and I
look around there's bungee Stakes
on elz and Leos in Laos so you know they
know this LZ had been used before yeah
which was Notorious in that area of
course so I'm trying to bring it to
everybody's got you know Cyclops eye
you know going up so we start up this
hill to get off the LLC and I'm in the
rear you know in this parades going up
the hill and and next next thing I know
we're on this high-speed Trail Dust is
this deep on it whoa the bamboo on both
sides is rub White
how wide was it it was it was it was at
least well I could tell you how wide is
because there's something stupid
happened later on but it was it was a
car it was it was a cart 15 and a half
okay right very good so we're going up
this Trail was the stock extended or
collapsed yeah this is this is it
okay caught Doherty leaned his car 15
down
I grabbed him and said what are you
doing
yeah get off the trail not only that you
got your gun laid out there
of course that was dirty's last mission
he quit so Eddie yeah anyhow
we started up this this Trail I'm I I
run up to the front I tell Wilcox we got
to get off this damn Trail and he said
we can't look at all this you know
because you had the bamboo on both sides
both sides it was like a bamboo was over
your head oh yeah yeah it'd be seven to
nine feet yeah you think was there so so
the we stop on the trail to give a team
okay right yeah with cubby yeah and I I
said God we gotta put Security on you
know what what the hell is going on here
and I look up and one of the guys on the
team had a can of apricots
wilcoxiously did I would good God this
is not a picnic here
so anyhow they find us opening and we
went down this hill and I'm I'm in the
back sure and you know they we walked
through right through a a biblack area
no yeah there were there was goddamn you
know they had all kinds of hooches
spider holes and yeah and stuff in it
and there was old bamboo hooches in
there and stuff it wasn't occupied at
the time but it had been so I knew this
this was not a place for a goddamn a
Welcome Wagon you know yeah yeah so
we're going down the hill and all of a
sudden
I look up what the trail we got up and
there's four NBA coming down the trail
on shorts
khaki Shores yeah yeah and pit helmets
and one of them had an RPG and the other
three had AKs and they're looking of
course we left Footprints all over the
goddamn plate jungle boots yeah yeah
they stand out yeah a little bit you
know
and they're looking all around and we're
down there in the brain I'm I'm down
there you know the buttons on my shirt
feel like Boulders I'm so close to the
ground you know yeah and there this one
guy stops and he looks right at me
so I get I'm getting ready I'm gonna
you're ready I'm gonna greet this guy
and he puts the gun back on his shoulder
and goes right down the trail just then
the World opened up the front of the
element hit him and really yeah and she
had bullets are flying everywhere and I
looked back up the trail and here comes
six of them running down the trail
so me and Ty you and and wilcox's uh a
tail Gunner shoot him you know yeah she
had obviously on rock and roll it wasn't
taking good aim I was just shooting low
and yeah and griezing them and knocked
them all down and one of them was
screaming his head off and so I I said
let's get off this let's get out of here
get we got to get with the group you
know because we're gonna file on that
jungle you know how that is yeah yeah
she had we couldn't see four foot in
front of us and
so I I heard this you know firing going
on and all this I heard somebody
crying I look over there and one of one
of the little people had been shot
through both arms
and so I try to get him up move him he
wouldn't move so I grabbed him and and
put them underneath my arm you know yeah
yeah and start dragging a potato
jungling all the time you're screaming
and like I kept shop so by myself and
there's about four bodies out in front
of them and he's on the radio and he had
two two uh two of the team with him and
they're just holes in the place down and
uh
I ran up and I grabbed Chop's foot and
he'll he almost
he was so focused on that yeah and what
it was we still had air cap we still we
still had the A1 East there right okay
and the gunships and he had called them
and told them what you know we were in
so I told him I he says they're
going to bring in nape and I said well
we got to Mark our position man
you know let him know
this sticks to kids you know I
don't know you know so Tim looks at me
and he says
okay I got my panel all crossed covered
me I'll crawl out and put the panel on
and I said okay that sounds like a good
idea
so Tim Tim starts crawling out and uh
puts the panel out and he starts
crawling back and he said oh God I'm hit
yeah he got shot he got trapped on his
ass from an RPG oh no you hit the trees
there yeah yeah the trees yeah RPGs and
he got he had he kept saying how bad is
it I said well you're bleeding
so he calls back and gets on the radio
and I said what I said where's Wilcox
and he said he's up there where we're
all split up
so I her Wilcox and hollering he said
are you guys okay you guys in Isis well
I got I got a wounded guy here he was
screaming so I said this I get
morphine you know yeah and I give up
full dose he was out you know
well I forgot this is an indigenous you
know 100
110 pounds of rice blower yeah you know
man I squeezed that dick but he didn't
feel any pain no he quit screaming that
was the best thing so oh Lord
and they were coming down the hill
of salt and it's down the hill and God
we're just I had I was stacked up
with magazines and I looked down there
and I rejected magazines still had
rounds in them that's all panicky we
were no kidding yeah I mean we were just
reason being shot and people people in
the entire you and tayu gets up and
throws a hand grenade and he hits a
goddamn tree and rolls down towards us
no yeah and I I cried and I said no hand
grenades
that I what I do I pick up a hanger and
they threw it up
but you had a better arm yeah I I
pitched baseball in the little league so
I know
so anyhow we heard this and Shaw
says
get your head down get your head down
nice one what the
then what happened was these gunships
came in right and got right over us the
top of us and they're they're hosed and
they got their miniguns and their holes
in the jungle up there we just come off
the trail right they were just shooting
all over the
so
all of a sudden the starts hitting
me and I said we're taking income it was
a brass yeah coming down and one went
down in my jacket this person yeah you
know I had scars on my neck yeah I had
that stuff to this day I guess that
scarf and that so anyhow that that
shit's happening and then they they they
expended all their man they just
crapped the place and they were still
taking fire too from top of the hill and
then I found out later shot told me the
cubby told them they were in formation
on the on a road
to come and get us they were having roll
call out there you know yeah and the
coverage says there's over a hundred of
them out there
so I'm glad I didn't know that at the
time yeah no kidding so anyhow that
happened Shoff says I said well we got
to get the DLC and secure that damn LG
for we can get the helicopters in and
they go well I hollered Wilcox I said
well Charlie we got to move from this
location
he said we can't move we're pinned down
I said pin down we gotta move out
of here
so Charles said we can't move now and I
said well since it goes crispy Critter
time oh for napalm
so a1e came right at us it was
not like out of a movie
you know the com Trails coming off the
guy sure Wings yeah and he he comes over
and tilts his wing out he can see us
because of the panel yeah yeah tilts his
wing at him and he's like this right
yeah yeah goes up on his Hill and hits
it with nape whoa and God damn all their
their their their uh hanger needs stuff
start going off and they're screaming
you know
it shots shots about to get a hard on
man he's so excited and then he says I
says I said can we put put a strike on
the LZ before we can you know if they're
terrible we'll burn them out shafts and
I'm already ahead of that
so he we put until we got the LZ on fire
no it was the dry season yeah of course
and all that bamboo started burning and
it starts blowing up the water in it you
know right we found like we were taking
incoming from the shampoo and all this
yeah all this crazy stuff so I I turned
around and and I'm of course I'm laying
on the ground in you know and low
profile it'd be at me's firing position
you know I guess
I look up and and shop and this other
guy had two SKS as they crawled up there
and
pulled these SKS as a lot of these guys
no kidding and I knew right away they
were security people yeah because they
were carrying SKS right and probably
weigh station guys so he
and he says
he said how bad is this my brother and
he was bleeding down this thing and I
said you're okay you're gonna be okay so
we hit there we hit the LZ and I'm
carrying the guy I get more sure yeah I
got him in a fireman's carry you know
and I'm carrying him across there and it
looks like a John Wayne movie yeah
hose an invisible enemy you know just
putting down fire to make me feel good
and we hit that you also had a lot of
enemy activity yeah oh yeah they were
still on their assets the only thing to
say is nape yeah I mean that scares me
you know I know just yet so that's the
reason it's outlawed they can't use it
anymore so anyhow we we hit the LZ you
know we getting I'm a kicking people get
in the God damn look at this get
claymore's out you know and all this
stuff and Wilcox was trying to get under
control
and uh and Tim was just for hot
like Tim I expected Tim to be and you
you know he had he was like you he had
to he still had the John Wayne mentality
he was good on the ground yeah
Invincible we were that funny hat yeah
yeah
so anyhow he's on the radio control and
all this and it should have been
Wilcox but came with cool he was
doing it all and uh so they put another
tbu strike up on the hill
and I put that the fire quit as soon as
we put that CBU in they quit shooting at
us it's like well let these
go and it's a cluster bomb
units yeah yeah yeah yeah they were and
they were the delayed fuse once was that
right yeah I kept going off you know
constellations I forgot about this yeah
yeah cbu29 I know that's implying cubby
I know it was indeed yeah all the crap
later in your song yeah I've become an
ordinance expert
Hank I upgraded from 5.56 to Naples
so anyhow the helicopters come in to get
us right and of course we're all jacked
up you know how that goes you know yeah
we're working on adrenaline it was
running low
yeah
so I
we run out of it and of course a slick
these guys are taking fire you know
I get they had the the doors were off
and they had them pull back both sides
right right so I had to the Indigent
been shot I threw him in the helicopter
kind of turned around and we're still
shooting up the hill and shock jumps in
the helicopter and I get on the strut
and I look down and the guy I carried I
threw him through the helicopter no you
had to throw him in again
jump off grab them yeah oh no yeah I
skittered
I think of course he didn't know
anything yet yeah but your adrenaline
was kind of popping by yeah my God Pat
and then we get back then we get back to
the grassy area you know yeah and you
know we got wounded people and stuff no
medical support so I run over to the A
Team over there and the cheap attic on
The A-Team I'd went through training
group with well no kidding yeah so he
come running out there with IVs and
stuff yeah he started you know doing
this
so I'll never forget shop had this it
had this SKS and he says
I said what do you got there for he said
no I'm not going to tell us we didn't we
didn't Engage The enemies
and had blood all over it yeah and it
ended up in the club at fob4 and it took
it back and hung it because we are the
first ones that bring back weapons oh is
that right yeah oh my God it was and
here here's the ironic part of the whole
deal uh
flb4 didn't write a submarine in in fob2
wrote itself for uh all of us they put
in wilcox's Silver Star and they
downgraded it and they wanted to give me
a silver star because I'd save the guy
yeah I met that criteria you know oh
yeah yeah and they said fob4 said well
we can't do that the one zero didn't get
the Silver Star again
so like I got the uh I got a broad star
would be right and so did yeah but here
we go shop didn't get a damn thing
I mean he he ran that whole show
Tactical Air Supply everything yeah he
did the whole damn thing and I don't
know how many he killed yeah
you know killed one for sure he had his
SKS so and then uh while we're still was
a hotel nine where you had again you're
on a bamboo you get on a trail and your
little people come back because there
was a four-legged encounter
with an elephant oh that was a no that
was out of nkp well that's nkp yeah
that's wrong with an elephant grass
right now but maybe we just have a quick
review that you're into a Target your
team is moving up the hill here again I
was strap hanging you know I became the
distractor and this is before you go to
fob 3 or before you come to fob1 yes
this is one of the things that I decided
that I need to get out of fob
they were on a mission to kill me yeah
it was kind of a case you couldn't say
nothing's better oh yeah yeah and I you
know shop and we decided we'd go
together as a team you know the the Marx
Brothers going up there so yeah so
anyhow
this was called a circus act I don't
know if I ever told you about that they
brought these no we go I was with uh
COBRA they assigned me to COBRA I took
two of my people with me it was like a
heavy team right and
Ron Brown and ass was our backup right
and we took Chase medic with us and
we're you've been you ran out of
Pancakes oh sure yeah yeah and nkp is
non-com Phenom Thailand right when their
weather sucked into Vietnam you can't
get into a Target into layoffs backside
right we go in the back side
um you know a black bird would take us
to nkp unload then at some point in load
up with helicopters with hh3s then well
what they did was they put you in
isolation there well yeah because the
little people weren't supposed to be in
layouts we're not allowed to happen yeah
so they locked them up in a compound and
then they we went to what we were
of course this is this is uh the age of
you know line of sight radios and all
the we were doing it was you know
the kids today their equivalent as us in
World War One guys you know yeah so
anyhow we're we're uh well you launched
you're in a Target no no no just we can
only remember they dip this is the best
part we're going in for the briefing oh
over the Target first they give us this
this they came in Samsonite suitcases
remember the results oh yeah the hard
cases sure well one of them was a
battery supply right and the other one
was the actual wiretap stuff and you had
to put it on wires and it had camouflage
wires oh yeah and you you know posted
yeah and they could they could fly over
and activate it from a plane yeah yeah
we saw those we never used it
we were the first ones to do this and
they brought Tech reps in from from from
Hollywood land right to tell us this
you know like it's uh John Wayne
movie sure you guys can do this and well
you you just don't tell me this
so we're in this briefing yeah for
the Target area and they got so you're
officially in a briefing for a wiretap
mission yes the first I was kind with
that okay yes and I'm
I'm just an add-on because they need
warm bodies to carry all this damn
equipment they give us and I was not it
was like eldest son I was not too
enthusiastic about this there's one
thing running Recon these wiretaps you
have to you as you know you have to go
down the objective to do that yeah
you're a bad buy country you know and
and
they give us a set of gas to climb a
pole because they were on telephone
poles yeah down the Ho Chi Minh trail it
has salad like my my zero one no this
was up by dmpm Foo on the other side no
kidding oh yeah we're waiting we're that
far north we were way up yeah that's a
problem
man we had no support yeah no gunships
all we had was a1es that flew for the
Pony Express guys right and those guys
and the Pony Express was the hh3s yeah
the bigger sikorskis stripped right
stripped yeah they have their door
gunner was a guy with an M16 a 30 round
first 30 round magazine I ever seen
those guys they always had the good
stuff first yeah yeah they had that
disposable
so anyhow we're into the briefing
and and Carlos Porter was over there he
was the staff sergeant Carlos Mr Wheeler
Dealer he was a combo chief he got his
way he must bought his way over here he
never saw combats so anyhow we're
sitting in there and they opened up the
map right yeah and this is where you're
gonna and I'll never forget this a1e
pilot says we take 37 of my body to cut
15 000.
and fifteen thousand yeah wow 57 Mike
Mike
the stuff they used over Hanoi yeah yeah
and they shot B-52 still that's it so
anyhow I looked at these goddamn Pony
Express polyps in their eyes
[Music]
I want this ain't gonna be fun I'll tell
you right now yeah so
they dropped they dropped us in
nine nine K from our objective nine nine
kilometers from where the polls where
we're supposed to do this yet and this
is a virgin country up there there's no
Mountain yards there's no
nothing but line attackers and elephants
and yeah and water buffalo you know and
and killed deer all over the place and
and parrots and the trees you know
Hocking at you so anyhow we get on the
ground
and
we start out of course we're all you
know how we hurry when you're old yeah
and you know about you're in hyper alert
yeah six hours later we're all picking
our noses and walking along and there
ain't no bad guys out here
you know so that's when we ran into the
elephant we figured well this is a
quicker way through yeah so we're going
down and all of a sudden they said again
did you have bamboo alongside you like
that it was elephant grass Alpha oh
which again it could be anywhere from
eight to ten it was way up yeah it was
all I know is this was a path we don't
have to break through because it was
Dayton us forever you know yeah little
people are all dead you know from and we
were carrying all this goddamn equipment
besides our load bearing equipment right
and it's you know that team the team
leader I won't mention his name but he
kept running back to me what do you
think what are you saying and I said
let's start a war and get out of this
goddamn gas deal
anyhow we're going down this thing you
know all of a sudden it hit me something
made this trailer it just you know
somebody wasn't up and it wasn't you
know driving their Ferrari down here or
something something and all of a sudden
all these little people start running
back I'm in the back yeah yeah it is
hell if it's tattering it away
no yeah then all of a sudden it hit me I
thought I saw a Polish
so the the time when gain going down the
trail we lost when you got overrun by
now everybody yeah thank God I mean he
didn't charge us I think he was more
shocked than we were
yeah
so anyhow we're scooting along and all
of a sudden two f4s come flying over
uh well what the are they doing you
know some boom boom boom yeah yeah
nicest man we're close to the road we're
closer than what we think you know yeah
yeah so I I would have a team leader I
said
uh Chuck Feller was a one one I says hey
I'm going to take Bella and one of my
people and I'm gonna go down here
and see what's going on you keep you
know put people in the secure position
and I give them a you know password and
challenge you know yeah I don't want
these shoot me up when I come
back in
so we we go down to and we all of a
sudden we out of nowhere we broke out
onto this grow system
I looked around and I says
oh there's no telephone poles here and
stuff to them because there's roads
and I heard all this talking Vietnamese
talking and
entire you comes over and grabs my arm
and he says PC and I said yeah I know it
you could hear him yeah like like this
is a big deal I know man so I'm looking
down there and there's a goddamn
anti-aircraft gun whoa
there you know 57 Mike Mike no it was it
was a 23. really yeah you know adults
like quad 50. yeah and these there were
three guys there and they were up there
both smoking cigarettes bullshitting on
rear security you know yeah yeah and
they had never seen American in their
lives so we were up so high and uh so I
I fought back and I said
uh I'm gonna think about this so I
go back and
well I was going to say who the one zero
is but I says look at
I think this is Mission Impossible he
says yeah yeah yeah
foreign
no telephone poles by me right we're not
only that yeah everybody's wore out and
I know the reaction time was five hours
whoa you get out there with that so if
you make contact you have five hours too
you know we wouldn't be killed yeah so
I says look at
let's get out of this damn place and he
said well how are we going to do that I
said we're going to go up we're going to
go up here and kill those guys
and I said then we're going to take
pictures and prayer if I we killed them
a bright idea
So I says here's the scheme
we're going to put Security on in
Security on the other and put the
Claymores out
then we'll have a 100 killer team go up
and grease them
okay
you know sounds like a good idea
panelists I said but before this
declare emergency sure get get the
helicopters coming this direction so
we're not going to do anything until you
know I can hear props you know coming
so and so we laid there forever
and it's starting to get Dusk you know
and I started panicking man what the
are we going to do now
so all of a sudden the Covey
they didn't call them cubby over there
they were flying they were flying the
tens okay yeah Broncos yeah uh
he shows up starts flying at oxygen
altitude over us and I could barely see
them up there and uh I said okay this is
this is it this could do it so
make a long story short went down there
indeed poor you know if they
didn't get their dicks out you know we
zipped them and took some pictures
grabbed grabbed a 30 a 23 Mike shell
you know yeah headed backward backwards
we picked out a we'd crossed an area
that we figured would be actually
two hours later they still
hadn't shown up the cubby was there but
they hadn't showed up
so they finally show up and they'll do a
Pony Express
they wouldn't land they threw a goddamn
ladder or something
and we got these all this junk and I
told I told the one zero I said what
take a snap link and snap all of our
goddamn equipment into the bottom you
know to keep it from slapping around
those aluminum ladders right sure beat
you to death and I said
and then we'll get in the helicopter
he said okay and I says I says me and
Feller will be the last one time you get
and you can well I'm the one zero I
should be the last one I said I'm this
is not a popularity contest I'll be the
last one on
he said okay
they start climbing first my God they
had one of the Indians falls off the
ladder oh no yeah well he was only up
maybe 10 feet right you know he just
couldn't do it
so I told him I said
everybody straddled a ladder and
snapping on a snap link
I said
we'll just you know we'll get to a safe
area they can land and we'll get it in
helicopter okay well the safe place is
every hook can't keep we flew all the
way back here on the ladders I was it
was so cold it was I mean we were Frozen
I mean we couldn't get we and here we we
landed in KP time they got they got
families there living there the Air
Force sure you know
and there's they're all out there it's
like Disneyland look at these crazy
Green Berets coming back right
a ladder
so we we get off we get off the ladder
and here's Ron Brown and ASP ready to go
they're getting they're getting on the
same Birds we got off of no kidding yeah
for another wiretap mission dad take our
stuff and they're going to continue on
to an so I told Enron was kind of
for hot I would he was good yeah yeah I
went to uh he was from my instructor
when I went to Halo school oh really
yeah he was in he was a hanky popper for
a long time yeah so anyhow and long
story short he gets I said Ron I grab
them you know we're friends for a long
time I said it's goddamn that's a bad
place out there and he said we'll get it
done well they got it done well yeah and
just for the record we have Ron Brown
Alan Boyer and Houston Houston there
were three Americans on ASP at that time
they get inserted they're on the ground
they made the tap
they actually made the tap they actually
made the tap okay now here we go how
much information do you gain from this
since you've been compromised
and and all this happened and what
happened was it same thing happened
These Guys these these these Pony
Express guys
they were used to doing these type of
operations they they put in these strata
teams these Thundercloud teams right up
north up way up North yeah way up North
and up my iPhone yes yeah these are all
NBA converts you know to give them a
Zippo lighter and a Honda motorcycle now
they're friendlies
but they did have some success up there
that was well we call them stay behind
teams yeah honestly got there they stay
behind oh really yeah they never picked
them up oh they were compromised they
couldn't go back and get them they and
they just gleamed information let's get
back to your mission here well anyhow
well they got they put us on a black
bird and got us out of country and sent
us back home
I mean within three hours I'm back at my
Hooch in fob4 and I get uh Leo Simpson
who was the operation Sergeant old
Delaware guy comes down to grasmine so
Pat come up the head Chad and I said oh
okay what's going on so after somebody
squealed on me and told me that I
started this award
and I was going to do the Fifth Fifth
Amendment to the Constitution I refuse
to discipline on the right to might
incriminate me yeah so anyway I get up
there and he says we've got problems and
I said
well and I started explaining to I was
going to say I had my cover story picked
out yeah right and I kept looking for
the 1-0 and he wasn't there to verify
that this was the truth of course we had
the that we'd placed up in that
kind of yeah fortified everything they
said uh ASP is in a word of and it
hit me I told brown man he says
I said wow how bad and he says uh the
Americans are gone well they sent uh
Chuck Fowler over there who's once we
ended up in the helicopter power well it
ran he was in charge of Aviation for the
FBI later on went through the whole
got and died for my brain amerism like
you know when he was 42 years old
so anyhow make a
uh
David got all the not here's here's what
everyone understand now we always had
this thing
that you got the Americans on first
right because they they dreamed the
Intel except the one zero
you know one Zero's last one to step on
them right yeah sure unless there are
scratch marks on it and then maybe he
was on them before but but anyway that
that was that was our sop line
but Ryan hadn't done that he put all the
little people on except his zero one his
Vietnamese zero one was still on the
ground
and they were on the they ladder again
they're on the line really yeah
they were on the ladder and Houston was
on the ladder going up and they started
taking fire
and a helicopter took off
and drugged Houston through the trees
and pulled a muscle at him
and and
and uh
Brown Boy George
Brown yeah or Ronnie is uh he's his
middle name we're still on the ground
with one in Dish and then
that was the last you ever heard of them
and they uh
two days later they sent Chuck in there
and he never got off his LZ
got lost two people got killed
put them into the same here with dumb
March 29 1968 and uh
and then the curse of ASP as you've
heard you know oh yeah we lost three ass
teams were completely wiped out over
time over to eight years yeah over eight
years that was the name they tried to
get rid of because it was a bad bad mood
you yeah and but uh
yeah and
you know to this day they still haven't
found Houston's and here we go again uh
you know I got I got into that recovery
crap you know on these cam dust thing
the only thing they'd find because the
soils acidic you know acidic yes and
they get your teeth
everything rots up for teeth all right
and they said they Brown's daughter was
married to a marine at Camp a gunnery
sergeant
and she she knew me I'd been in contact
with her because she kept asking about
her father and sure and her him and his
wife had broken up and she loved their
father and thought her mother was a
you know that kind of right
and then she was married to a gun home
Marine on top of it all a beautiful girl
she got a hold of me and says they found
my dad and I won't accept it
and that's when Jack Crowell yeah got
him back because Jack was wearing his
bracelet bracelet yeah and Jack called
me up and says can you and
convince her we have the Barney and I
said how do I know
and you're on my my MOS is not pathology
you know this is many years later oh
yeah this is the reunion stuff was
called sure and so anyhow he uh they
found one tooth and get this they
wouldn't let them drill into it because
they said it was his tooth
and wow and I tried to convince her to
bury him in Arlington and make him bring
to horses in the carriage and all that
out
but she buried him with his mother in
Texas
yeah they also uh had the remains for
Alan Boyer yeah and he was buried in
Arlington yeah did not I was I was stuck
at work oh okay couldn't make it
I'll never forget Ellen told me later on
they had those uh Thunder
writers
yes yeah and Ellen says if you guys do
that to me I'm gonna come back and haunt
you
yeah he's a dope ain't gonna
leave my hers yeah so I'm sure when
Eldon died he made Jerry's wife did that
yeah too they had the out to
date they did bring a lot of glue went
they had the SOA Riders sure Lou told me
that that little was in North Carolina
the town he was in from well no that was
uh the one they had down North Carolina
was for um Donnie's shoe okay when they
recovered it they had the writers there
and they had that was in 69 shoe came up
in my hand right he he went M.I.A in um
with uh Gunther Wald yeah and another
Brown yeah and that was uh November 3rd
16. I just got back to CCM oh did you
see yeah yeah
yeah I don't know it was his hometown
was some place in the South but then
they it was close enough to Arlington
they escorted his body all the way to
what was left well yeah and I've I've
talked in fact yesterday I talked to
Alan Boyer's sister
Judy yeah Judy I talked to you she
always talked she says you're the only
person I knew that knew my brother nice
well Tim knew him yeah Tim didn't want
to talk and so for context too this is
68 and by that time Villa Rose's team
had been wiped out we had two other
teams wiped out in May
um that uh St Alaska was hit with John
Allen every bar in that team was kill
supper John and he in need for a dare to
yeah and they brought him back
here's John Allen
he blamed himself for everything and I
tried to tell him I said you can't
control life no
yeah
well the the crazy thing about Apple
before I went there with 16 of us to be
one zeros and stuff right and by the
time we got out of country as guys that
made it to November
64 or 68 you know to go home there was
only four of us still there
wow and of the four uh three of us have
been wounded sure the other ones that
either been killed or matter of fact
back so
let's go back to when the young Pat
Watkins from Indiana
I'm going to serve God and Country you
join the Marine Corps First and what
year was that sir
1956. I was I'd run the state track meet
three days before and then I was down
because they I was being recruited at
partial scholarships to track college
and my mother
said I think the Marine Corps is a good
option she'd had enough for me
because the whole family deals on I
don't know it was an Iwo Jima and so
anyhow I I went and joined the Marine
Corps and it was a whole company of us
from Indiana that called us the Ernie
Pyle company really yeah because Ernie
Powell's from Indiana sure right and
people don't realize Ernie Powell made
their all through
Europe yeah yeah would always patent all
this crap he the war is over in Europe
and he decides well I'm going to go with
the Marines now so he goes to Okinawa in
the Marines and he was on akashima a
small island off right and a sniper
killed him yeah God
so Marine Corps and during that time the
Marine Corps you meet this lovely young
lady a fellow Marine Carol yeah she we
did it for a pay increase
yeah I was I just made I made sergeant
and I hit all the bars in Oceanside 50
times
I better settle down and I bet care I'm
just so funny I gotta she was running
for what they used to have a rodeo there
every year that was that RCA Road well
Doug was when he was a Roper right yeah
he did the RCA circuit and uh they had
it and they brought uh they had a
bonanza
yes it was a little costs and yeah and
they brought movie stars there for this
it was a fundraiser for the Marine Corps
League right you know that that uh
our our our buddy is uh was President
enough for right yeah so anyhow the
future forms of America yeah right so
anyhow they Carol who's running for
rodeo queen
no yeah they they took women Marines
yeah sure and stuff and she was running
for Road they they brought it down and
bought it one of the I called it the
Dale Evans outfit
with the tassels on it yeah yeah it was
blue and got her got her a horse she'd
never rid a horse in her life you know
she's from Tacoma Washington
so they sent her to training
to learn how to ride a horse because
they had to be in this parade yeah
so anyhow she she wrapped rodeo queen
and she came out second I'll never
forget they had the speech they had to
give it for the contest the girl won the
contest with some Colonel's daughter of
course I told him I was drink Carol yeah
she said it's okay she didn't get an
outfit but she still got her outfit does
she oh yeah
got pictures I'll have to send you a
picture with the horse he's got a
palomino so any other pedaled in in this
and she's got to get this is when the
you get votes people bought tickets for
you of course she had all the women
Marines voting for him again
and I said I told her they stuffed The
Ballad on you again
they say Trump thinks he was screwed
this is really screwed so
any uh anyhow we're she's getting them
she's got to give this speech yeah and
she's got to talk about Franklin
Roosevelt during World War II you know
in the emergency
and she calls it you know it's Franklin
Delano or Roosevelt right and she calls
him Delano and I'd practice this speech
order about 30 times Well Delano's
accurate No it's the line no it's not
Delano Del Norte
so anyhow she sheep out and I started
laughing we'd worked his son she looks
and gives me these daggers stairs you
know Carol oh yeah like don't screwing
me so she she got all these pictures
with horse and yeah and
and all the guys come over and there it
was a guy from Rawhide too
oh it's Clint Eastwood yeah yeah Clint
Eastwood he was there and they had the
uh half Gun Will Travel right sure boom
yeah boom he was there of course this
was all a PR thing you know for Marine
Corps and these are all these guys
uh come in and so she she had she still
got all those pictures of her with these
guys so anyways she she comes in second
you guys got married when
got married in 62 62. it'd be 60 years
wow
I can't believe she put up with you all
these years she didn't put up with me
man she just she just cashed the checks
and I've never cashed a check in my life
I have no idea how much money we got in
the bag yeah
I'm the same way she's the adult
leadership man okay so at some point you
go
um there's another oh what happened what
happened how do you go from there you
transition to Special Forces well no and
what happened in 62 after we got married
the Cuban crisis thing broke out Cuban
Missile Crisis yeah yeah Kennedy played
chicken with Gorbachev right or crucial
cruise ship Gorbachev was a good guy
he's the one that tore her down the wall
that they're trying to Ronald Reagan
yeah they teamed up yeah so anyways so
anyhow next thing I know I'm on a
goddamn cargo ship
heading towards the canal
with the first Marine Division
and I was attacked I was I was in base
Marine Corps base right but I was a
camel guy and they needed a common guy I
needed idiots of string a wire you know
and I was a sergeant I was a section
chief so I'm on this guy and me girls
only been married for
two weeks or something like that we're
living notion side down by the pier
outside California yeah down how about
up here down by the Anna and a studio
apartment would roll away bad
and she's still on the core yeah but but
she she wants that because she likes to
beach better and she likes the Marine
Corps yeah and you know the Grunion or
running yeah so anyhow I'm on this
goddamn boat heading to the Canal Zone
yeah to this and we it's typical the
Marine Corps has always had this opinion
if you need to know we'll tell
you you know yeah and nobody told us
anything oh I know is this is unamel
and I you know all this you know it's
serious when you get yeah and then you
know I knew it was because the boat deal
still remember when they bringing the
missiles in sure and uh that's when it
had the YouTube photographs that yeah
the shop had YouTube playing down yeah
so anyhow make a long story short was
that uh Kennedy played chicken with him
and says
you know if you don't turn these things
back he took
uh the Russians the Soviet Union in
those days that uh
there's going to be a cloud yeah we
still have nuclear Services superiority
so we make it there and I end up on a
golf course at gitmo Bay
stringing wire between 105 positions
which is this guy with pillows and
and this and this is after the ships
that turn around and move back right
they Chip Away chicken and they moved
them back they had done because he you
know they had the whole they had the
whole sixth Fleet out there they were
you know the battleships Cruisers
aircraft carriers that was a crisis of
the moment
90 miles away been a nuclear war you
know sure and uh and and basically uh
uh Curtis Le man those guys wanted the
war you know and Bobby Kennedy talked
John out of it says let's see if they
got any guts yeah you know we're
Boston Mafia let's see how this
works so anyhow they back they they
turned they turned around well they
still had in there you know yeah
they had artillery any aircraft and
everything else and they basically
Kennedy basically told him well we'll
move to our missiles out of Turkey
if you move everything out of it it was
a face-saving so at what point do you
leave the Marine Corps
and how long is it till you enter the
Army and then you say I want to wear
that funny hat I uh I left Marine Corps
in 63. okay and I didn't join the Army
right Carol's Bobby joined you no no no
work
work enjoyment you know yeah yeah honest
labor which I was not accustomed to
so what happened was Carol's dad was a
electrical contractor in Washington
state they lived up on the peninsula
right a little town called Port Townsend
right on right on on the bay and uh so
we and Carol's pregnant
but uh your first girl yeah with Kelly
Kelly and uh of course you couldn't in
those days if if you got married you
couldn't have kids if a wife was in the
Marine Corps was that right yeah yeah
they yeah that they did still saying we
didn't issue you that with your sea bag
the Marine Corps was definitely
masculine oriented I mean when I I went
to Okinawa in the third Mar did you know
the Air Force and the Army used to all
got there when I went back there you
know in the first group and Carol was
there my kids went to school there yeah
and uh but the Marines even the
Commanding General couldn't have his
wife there because we're Deployable we
can't you you know we can't be worrying
about that and even back in those days
when you deployed your wife had to leave
base oh then we they made me Carol move
off base yeah yeah yeah she we yeah we
were out looking for yeah in those days
it was like um
yeah you got a wife and family but we
didn't issue a life and family that's
your problem it was it was really tough
yeah not come it's like when I went to
the seventh group when I got to DSC
right right uh the command sergeant
major Garen I mean take you know they
took all of us guys to the seventh group
and of course that's like Disneyland I
never seen anything yeah we were living
in World War II Huts sure buildings and
pray and they got climbed they had a gym
they were climbing warm you know all
kinds of Weights
that's a modern day special yeah all
these guys look like they were on
steroids and out of Gold's Gym in there
you know like you were tattoos all over
them and I could now me and Tommy
Shook and so anyways you're you're
wandering on me so what I like to do is
uh when did you join your well what
happened was I went to work for her dad
right and it was apprenticeship a dick
digging ditches for what for conduit
sure yeah yeah
and I said even a Marine Corps looks
better than this crap so Carol's ready
to drop a kid yeah yeah and like and I
said God I need medical insurance or
something what's going to happen
so I this is the I went down to
Bremerton Washington where they used to
have the Missouri Battleship used to be
right before they moved it to Hawaii
right so I went to Bremerton it was the
closest thing for a recruiting station I
talked Carol and I said I'll go join the
Air Force
well we'll have a good life that's right
you know you got good food yeah not only
had I've been to Hell I've been in the
Marine Corps for seven years yeah yeah
I'm just just I could stand on my head
and stack babies so they had one of
these like they do now they have all the
services in one area and one building
right
uh so I walk in there and the Air Force
guy these belts hanging out his kneecap
you know kind of guy and me coming out
of the Marine Corps I'm one judgmental
from yeah yeah so look at
this guy and he says can I help you and
I says uh wait a second Carol was out in
the car waiting on me
yeah we had a Volkswagen bug you know of
course yeah bought it in Oceanside yeah
for sixteen hundred dollars new they had
to for this for the spare gas tank was a
knob if you had extra gowns yeah yeah
because you didn't have a gas gauge no
gasket
you knew you had one gallon yeah
he kicked it over so anyway she said not
in the car waiting for me now I walked
there I said I can't do this girl
I says she said well you're not going
damn Marines you know but she spent
three years she knew she knew sorry says
but let me see I said I can't join the
Navy I said that's the last half it's
like a marine I can't join the Navy I
can't hold my hand up I'll be afraid I'd
run into a marine I know so if I walked
back in there and the recruiter
for the um for the Army
was a former paratrooper
really yeah and he had a 187 patch been
in Korea right with the one he was
starting first class
and he was outside smoking a cigarette
bye and he looked at me and he says your
prior service
and this is yeah
you are a marine no yeah of course I had
a short haircut yeah yeah and all this
stuff you were squared away yeah he
looked at me and you know and my shirt
was tucked in and you know I said Well
there must be a marine so he looked down
and I said yeah he says
are you looking for a career
really I says I've been through that
seven years in the corner he says that
all counts he said well we'll forgive
you
he says
how would you like to join the Army and
I figured well hell I can find a racket
in the army man it's a big place yeah
you know so he gets in there and he says
you ever think about jump School
that's what I thought about it when I
was single a long time ago and he says
you ever think about
being in that Airborne your nieces just
like the Marine Corps but they don't
talk like Swabbies
and I says yeah of course I'm not
running this by Carol right yeah no so I
he gets in there and he's just got the
brochures and stuff and he says I said
well I'd been on local now or when the
first group was there yeah and it was
kind of like
don't talk to those guys you know
in the Marine Corps is like you know
sure was losing enough people they
didn't want us
yeah and add one eight uh the 173rd was
on okay uh sure got another key down
yeah before they moved into Italy right
so their newer Airborne Troopers out
there and God always liked those jump
boots man they really look good yeah and
uh so I walked back in there and I said
what what can I can I have in this he
said you
he said I can get you anything you want
but comfort
and I'll never forget that I said well
I'm used to that that yeah
he says
how would you like to go to jump School
I said yeah
he said I can get you jump school and
Raintree School
and Rangers go damn Ranger potassium it
was it was just a school assignment deal
yeah and I said can I get in Special
Forces and he said now you got to take
all these tests and all this crap he
says you can go to 101st or 82nd
Airborne Division if you make it on a
jump what year is this 63 okay yeah so I
says well I thought I'll make it I'm a
former Marine man I can walk on
water
so he uh they signed me up for jump
school yeah yeah and the whole Rag and
he says okay you got to be here tomorrow
to be sworn in
and I said where do I go do I go to
Penny he said no you got to go to Fort
Ord for clothing issue get gotta get
gotta get that that Marine Corps
yeah and and get you and your I says as
well how's this work do I have to go to
basic training and he says now you've
been through hell you were a marine
Corporal Camp you don't have to do that
well no kidding yeah oh yeah I went in
this at Corporal I lost one rank right
so anyhow I would I went I went out told
Carol I says I come in to be sworn well
she thought I was going in the Air Force
and she says where are they going to
station she's been on air force process
before how well they lived yeah you know
these surprises these guys you know
these guys never seen her see rash in
Canada in their lives you know yeah you
know that let alone alert so
this so I walked in I says uh
that that wasn't going to work for me
Carol she said you didn't go back into
them
see they were going to send me to
Okinawa and for yeah that's the reason I
got out because she was ready to have a
kid now sure and you know bring like you
know Marine Corps no wasn't in your sea
bags we don't give a but yeah if
you're an officer who you might care so
you enlisted so I got I broke the news
to her dad was going in oh my God but I
didn't tell her I was going to jump
School
so anyhow I went I went back to Port
Towns and we were living in a little
apartment had a ringer wash machine and
and she's getting ready to drop the
kid any day and I says
I got to go down to the school and she
would I said they got monkey bars and
stuff down there let's see so what do
you need to do that for and I says well
I gotta pass this test
yeah
she said what test
I support Airborne school she's a
paratrooper
she said I knew I shouldn't let you go
in there by yourself
so I go to I tried I take the volts away
and I drive the Lord and that was a
culture shock to me yeah I would never
been on the Army Post night these guys
walking around overweight some of them
in it you know or it was a replacement
place it wasn't real Harmony right it
was all a bunch of and it was basic
training still there there's basic
training there then
so I could they put me in the transit
billets and this guy who was in charge
at Transit bills
that Marine Corps would have shot him he
was so he looked so cool yeah yeah I
don't know how he you know of course
army in those days PT testerone for
infantry people right all these he was a
spec five on top of that I didn't know
what a spent five
five yeah and uh so I'm in there and and
all these recruits had just graduated
and half of them are going to OCS
yeah yeah okay
and uh of course they you know the Army
you know that was
OCS was Canon fodder deal with these
kids and stuff I love it so Vietnam
wasn't really no no it wasn't it they
didn't have any they just had special
forces in the bicycle Mac B you know
Marine Corps had people over here
as advisors to the Vietnamese Marines
Navy had their so I I go there and
I I get there to have one of these
epidemics of
God that Airborne kind of flu where they
shut everything down oh yeah
and every they opened all the end you
ever been award it's right on the bay
that's where the Freshman went through
and yeah same thing cool to open up all
the windows or hell I thought I was in
Siberia man I was used to Southern
California and that breeze had come off
the The Bay out there man that's where
we used to have baseball games their
Candlestick Park and the guys would be
wearing long johns and everything so
anyhow I get through that yeah so I
got I go back to there because I had to
be at Jump school right and so I had to
leave Carol the car she didn't have
anything and I was just going sure I
guess a plane I get back the day I got
back there she drops Trace Kelly and
luckily I had Insurance it cost me five
dollars for it so two days later I I
caught I caught a Greyhound bus
couldn't afford to go in a plane right
right caught the Greyhound bus and I
traveled all the way across the country
and went to jump school and got out of
jump school and they went to Pathfinder
school so
um at this point in time we've gone way
past two hours and what I like to do is
we have to come back and do a second
interview with you and so
um at this point in time if you don't
mind there Sergeant I like to close out
here but when we return and start this
next podcast I'd like to start at August
23rd 1968 do a little background to what
that day was and then take off from
there and then follow up with your
career subsequent to that and if you
don't mind and it's at this point we
like to thank
um
all the members of the military today
are serving our country the border
patrol our First Responders and all the
law enforcement and of course today were
February 27th and the Ukraine is alive
in the news and we pray for all the
people there and our military on standby
and uh We're a nation that's watching
Another War unfold at this point in time
we also want to thank the men and women
who have served in years past Heroes
Like Pat Watkins men that I have had the
pleasure of serving with and to whom I
turn to for Infinite Wisdom during my
days at fob 1. we also want to remember
and salute the men and women who have
not been able to return to this day and
at this date we have
1583 Americans that are still listed as
Mia from the Vietnam War in Southeast
Asia and of course when we close we want
to thank Jocko willink for making this
possible we appreciate his support his
team Echo Charles and now the team's
been joined by Carrie Helton and we
thank him for coming aboard to help us
all here to bring sarcast production to
you
again through Jocko willing Productions
and saw Chronicles thank you for today
God bless America